Dolly Parton showed up to some football
game and she was dressed like a Dallas
Cowboys Cheerleader and she was wearing
her you know short shorts and her highly
cropped shirt and she did a performance
and Dolly Parton is 77 years
old and if you look at it she
looks she looks
good but I don't think anyone says DOI
looks bad they might say she this is
disordered because Dolly Parton is 77
years old 77y old not be dressed like
this they should not be dancing like
this and so that's disorder but also
Dolly partner is a kind of beloved
figure even conservatives love Dolly
she's not one of these radical leftist
she's sort so what what are we
conservatives concerned with order and
propriety and etiquette and gracefully
aging and family values and what are we
to think about dol's performance Dolly
Parton is a unique case Exempted from
all rules of etiquette